siete pronti a cagarmi nelle mutande o
perché questo gioco fa al caso nostro un
seconda parte di elsie del gioco
incredibile ambientato a torino
buona visione a proporle non so perché è
l'unico modo guardone succede le
migliori sui quadri mario schifano
solivo soliva a porta a porta profumo
ridotta eccolo qua basta salire di sopra
tiracchia che schifo forza sto vedendo
ma che vai vai tra sedia con la puntata
ha posto a posto sarebbe molto più
facile data se sto tizio che sarà la
vita del salto cosa che non credo abbia
alla prendi questo non significa non
l'ho preso l'aveva niente perché mi
serve a fare di secondo me lo prendi lo
creda
sono vivo per miracolo ma l'ho preso e
adesso devo andare di soffre
semplicemente ok
che schifo i topi maledizione ci arrivo
sono poi sono messi secondo me sì vado
ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta chiudi la
porta
che schifo i topi ragazzi orribile basta
spese spegna musiche è stato bruttissimo
o santo iddio non senza festa va dicendo
per il gioco allora siamo riusciti a
sopravvivere al seminterrato ho trovato
mag e o abbiamo soltanto acceso alla
fine dei giochi la la corrente non è
niente non ho fatto niente di troppo
strano in realtà
buongiorno finalmente si è aperta st
porta permesso ok bella casa torinese fu
macchiando va così apprendiamo angelo de
santis una nuova psichiatria va bene va
bene
camilla drawings mai bene in questo
giorno è mio compleanno mano nella mano
lo festeggiamo cara mamma caro papà sono
tanto felice di essere qua bellissima
filastrocca vi voglio bene camilla ok a
me che cazzo me ne frega a me tutto
studio
knock knock di sicuro a torino non
scrivono propri occhi mi scrivono e
hogan è però non è un ragazzino ragazzi
non mi va la torcia al 1850 non guardano
sono guardate voi in una torcia io dove
cazzo viaggi dove sai cosa faccio aiuto
basta piangere che fastidio basta
sbattere le porte oddio oddio cosa c'è
quella destra
mi scusi ma benché successo i quadri si
presta a volte si porta a porta segreta
fatta via via foria le palle fuori dalle
palle fuori le palle
ecco pronto vodafone.de toscani sconi
bella zio sto bene toscani stavo meglio
in provincia d'arezzo
no ragazzi basta basta basta con queste
robe demoniache di tool sorella morta
chi si è chiuso qua dentro
ti apro non c'era niente grazie a dio
no basta mi chiamo aspetto di nuovo le
luci ho fatto tutto sto casino per poi
alla fine trovarmi e lucidi nuovo spente
e allora cosa è servito comunque per
essere una deve per la lunga e cioè
pensavo molto peggio io vorrei veramente
voce il frigo apre aperto non si tiene
aperto il frigo che va tutto male
soprattutto è un peccato perché poi
c'era il cibo buono è quindi era peccato
farlo andare a male chiuri brillo che
cazzo succede a cascata la mezzo ma io
ma cosa fate schifo ma vergognatevi ma
che che ma cos'è ma cos'è ma cos'è
ragazzi ma cos'è ma vi giuro orribile
orribile le cuffie sono intatte ma per
miracolo divino grado grazie gesù che ci
protegge anche le cuffie perché se no
questo no ragazzi vi prego no no basta
basta basta basta basta sta roba per
cortesia ecco qua via nonché quale tu
sia figo però mamma mia a quella era la
porta che ha murato va bene ok è questa
qua e una parte nascosti ma della casa
come se avesse fatto tipo degli
esperimenti qualcosa che non voleva
essere visto che ora si scoprisse
se la sarebbe la italy italiche posto
cipe la madonna quante bottiglie del
vino per terra che porta a questo
armadio non c'era niente nell'armadio al
suicidio nascosto no perché il vino ha
portato bohli montegrosso madonna frega
niente se sei stanco di correre
c'è stata nelle mura di torino e 26
stanze la porta dell'inferno
c'è un codice a cielo se è giusto sono
un fenomeno ed era 12 55 79
ma cosa cosa non me l'aspettavo mai
questa come va come va dai 12 57 9 borri
fifa e uefa
il casino che casino madonna orribile
my blog cellar door with good on board
dove minchia le trovo non lottare sia
per favore che già al casinò ma se mi
nascondo lei non mi vede cosa fatta solo
nascosto hai fatto capire davvero come
ha fatto capire il vero meno nascosto
benissimo come ha fatto mi chiama
intelligente anche cattin avrei mai
detto perché non posso correre in studio
cell
corro faccio un metro e sono stanco
quindi c'è un problema sala questa st 18
st di tutta la prima porta apriamo la
calabria mostra prima portare la porta
chiusa cure matthew la botta che faccio
è tutto chiuso
tanto mi sono ripreso dalla coltellata
nel mentre che ho aspettato ma l'azienda
no no no e non posso scendere vai vai
l'ho tirato un calcio mentre mi
accoltellava mi sono salvato perfetto
nell'armadio l'armadio di quello che ha
visto che non è mai visto
ecco la tegola l'ho presa nel momento
sbagliato come dice la zia
il bello è che non è bello per niente
che non riesco a sprintare perché quella
là mi raggiunge subito s'è andata sono
andata piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano buono muro da un
altro hanno trovato un altro sono forte
sono due sono finite quante woode award
3 dove trovarne mannaggia il kaki non lo
so due o tre ragazzi ho preso l'ultima
con ansia addosso che non ho mai avuto
nella mia vita da quando gioco mai devo
solo arrivare alla porta la bordelli
corri dai e dai laici fermata violet è
chiusa la c'è la mano di chi ce l'ha
chiamata cellar door io no mica fare ce
n'è ancora una c'è ancora una chiave
mito impossibile ed ora trovo giancarla
chiave lo dice ancora una una good and
clank e imposto in notturna tetre dove
cacchio è l'ultima yes yes no sta tocco
ma visto dove era qui hanno tirato un
calcio corri corri gianfranco cori in ti
vorrei e tu non ti vota non ti votano di
votare l'ho trovata non troverò mai più
perché non sono anche due case o trovata
corri mi prende non ci credo
raga e roero and roll it e poi ho preso
l'ultima amy è comparsa c'è poco aspetta
che la prende e ti prende per
ok ok ok ok ok forse potrei potrei
potrei farcela non è detto adesso
teoricamente non ce la fa e speriamo che
si apre ti prego apt perché non ne ho
altre nicchia chiudi la porta che la
porta è barricati ok dichiarato vai
ancora una ancora ma 18 io santissimo a
in safe for now for now to sorella morta
nicchia che ansia buche mamma mia che
cosa incredibile ho giocato el sayed un
horror in provincia di torino e non è la
mia scuola media se guardate c'è un
video di un capodanno fatto parigi e
capodanno 2017 che se lo guardate vedete
una tipica casa di torino horror
ecco esattamente quel vero che esca il
gioco definitivo perché è una bomba
verano giu anche se un oro ancora in
demo era già incredibile è il fatto di
sempre stata torino mi gasa un sacco che
i ragazzi iscrivetevi senza turisti
lasciati piace video e noi come sempre
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]
ma